so here's what i want to point out
at a time
when we've got this story from the daily
from the daily mail and i can't show you
the headline because uh youtube might
take it down
hunter biden's laptop was was leaked you
know and so there's new information
coming out about the things he was doing
i just find it funny that on on this day
something really really bad comes out
it's also the day we get the the uh the
verdict in the trial for johnny depp and
amber hurt i'm not saying this
conspiracy i'm just saying
what a distraction what did you even say
bread in circuses
hunter biden
was searching for milf crack cocaine
adult content wow i just thought that
was funny because it's like well you
know he's into it right he's looking for
someone who's just like him
he was looking for
no no get this got this he was looking
up adult content on pornhub lonely widow
that is dark
his brother's widow and so he's like i'm
into this yeah and he's looking it up
that's creepy but here's the craziest
thing here's what they say
there's an image that says dad on 2018
1022 and it's a link to pornhub premium
sent to dad
who is hunter biden's dad
joe biden here's what they say though
imessage records appear to show hunter
sent a link to a pornhub page to a phone
number he had saved in his context book
as dad on october 22nd 2018 however
other texts show he and joe biden used
each other's phone numbers at various
times so it is unclear whether the
president was using that number at the
time how does it even work daily mail
you realize that also means it could
have been joe sending it to his son
it could have been joe sending it to
himself
joe biden being like oh this is a really
good video got me off i'm gonna i'm
gonna save this one for later by sending
it to myself at least he paid for
premium
yeah
yeah you don't want to get the cheap
stuff huh here's the craziest thing
about this is yo look i mentioned this
in the intro to the to the show i don't
care if hunter bion wants to do weird
stuff you know everybody's everyone
there's the meme where it's like the
person's dying and they're like delete
my search history because everybody's
you know searched for weird things
they'd be embarrassed by
if hunter biden wants to watch lonely
widows okay dude that's your thing but
if joe biden is using the same phone
number as hunter then how do we know how
do we differentiate between the business
dealings of hunter biden and joe biden
this sounds to me like
just evidence on top of evidence that
joe biden was using his son as a proxy
to do deals on on the side while he was
you know influential in government
vice president or otherwise did you see
this email there's a story that came out
today about an email sent between james
biden and joe er and hunter biden did
you see this i think this is part of
this like drop what is it uh in an email
james told hunter him hunter
you quote you need to call me now dot
dot dot just got off the phone with your
father we have the two biggest days of
our business life in front of us five or
six or seven exclamation points uh we
must be smart and everything or
everything goes up in smoke please call
me you must all caps remain calm timing
could not be worse common measured
paybacks can come later
so we have this right here
what is this what is this in reference
to like what are they doing i just i
don't know let me let me read this as
quote james and hunter biden were in the
midst of a lucrative deal with chinese
executives at the time while joe biden
was out of public service for the first
time in nearly half a century having
left the vice presidency a few months
earlier hunter biden turned to his uncle
at least as much as to his famous father
for emotional support hunter also relied
upon james biden who goes by jim and is
known as jimmy within the family on
matters of dollars and cents within days
of that exchange hunter received another
email from his uncle urging him to take
advantage of a financial opportunity
related to joe biden
right so i mean we can all laugh at the
ridiculous and deeply personal photos of
of hunter biden gross you know him his
crack addiction and his his illicit
activities and all that stuff but i when
they said that they shared phone numbers
right away i was like yo
are we all going to laugh that he sent
this link or are we going to recognize
this appears to be evidence that they
were using communication platforms
interchangeably they were sharing bank
accounts
joe was doing the illicit dealings it's
not hunter biden it's joe biden who's
doing it hmm well i can't think of any
other reason for them to share a phone
number surely they have the funds to
both afford sepsis
deniability thing maybe i don't know is
that it that joe was doing some work
he's like oh yeah hunter also uses it
probably wouldn't be for you or i or any
person of normal means who was
committing that kind of a crime right
yeah allegedly committing that crime of
a crime right people don't share cell
phone numbers with other people that's
insane you might have a family plan with
multiple numbers on the plan the only
reason you would use the same number as
someone else is to obfuscate it i can't
why else would you they they're filthy
rich they don't need it
for money they don't need it we can we
can take it on its surface and just be
like hunter biden sent his dad porn yeah
that's what i think happened so
maybe unit i think
let's take a look at what's going on
with this guy hunter biden
uh his dad sniffs little kids
consistently his dad talks about how
when he was younger the little kids were
rubbing my legs what did he say uh
sheamus oh the hairy legs i got hairy
lighter kids would rub them yeah so
here's a guy we've seen
grab women and sniff them grab children
grope children
here's a guy that's been accused by tara
reid of
unspeakable acts
and then you take a look at hunter biden
sexually depraved
crack addict i'm wondering like how does
someone who's brought up in this like
privileged family turn to this kind of
life
maybe
something a deep trauma from his past
made him turn to drugs to escape
maybe he's
gone through why would he be sending his
dad porn
maybe his dad was abusing him and that's
why they share phone numbers and send or
he sends adult content to his dad
because they had an inappropriate
relationship when he was younger i'm not
saying it's a fact i'm not saying i have
evidence i'm saying i look at this stuff
and what i see is i'd be willing to make
the bet i'm like this guy's got
deep sexual problems you know i'm
looking up
hunter's mom and brother died in a car
accident yeah and he was actually in the
car with them i would say
1972 so hunter that might have just
destroyed his mind but when you add into
the fact that uh their dad his dad
sniffs little girls and and gropes
children even little boys and kisses
them i'm like the guitar right tara reed
accusations are unconscionable it's
unconscionable that it wouldn't be
investigated that right before he's
running for office a girl comes down
it's like he pushed me up against the
wall and fill in the blanks look it up
it's disgusting i just want to i just
want to stress i mean we all have seen
the videos of joe biden groping and
kissing little kids what's the one with
the redhead girl who's like she's like
shirking away from him and looking at
him all awkward there's a whole super
there's like super cuts yeah isn't there
one way like grab a little boy's head
and lifts it up and pulls him in and
kisses him
there's like
didn't he he kissed his granddaughter on
the lips didn't he i believe so yeah was
that that's that's something that
happened right yeah i remember that
recently yeah also like it's like it's
because he's older it's like it's just
it was a different time when he was when
he was younger it's totally normal it
was back when like humphrey bogart would
backhand women on camera and it was cool
in movies that was like that was in the
50s yeah i wasn't like the 40s no i mean
i i don't i don't care if that's true
the new york post ran the story in 2020
joe biden kisses granddaughter on the
lips during iowa rally i mean it is
shocking enough that they're like this
is a story and they show images of him
kissing his granddaughter on the lips
okay
in fairness is there an actual video of
this because
i could oh there is because i could see
somebody turning a cheek on accident the
wrong way and you get that photo again
i'm not saying that's what happened both
puckering yeah you're right okay that
looks weird but i mean it's it's family
you know sometimes you you kiss family
members on the mouth and it's just like
a i've seen that happen before um
so but it's when it's the girls that
aren't his like the
his buddy's daughter that's like trying
to get out of the way when he's grabbing
at her and like there's a camera the
picture's taken like oh
then you have to ask the question is it
better or worse when he's not related to
them because that's a slippery slope to
go down too i i have no doubt that uh
that hunter was deeply abused like i've
i've thought that for a really really
long time seeing his acting out in his
behavior this is not
okay so the drugs i understand a lot of
rich kids get into a lot of
um really distasteful drug practices but
his his level of acting out is very much
a case of like actual abuse and for that
i do feel bad for him and the way i feel
like his dad used him for um business
deals what are you laughing look at this
fact check from the ap
photo shows biden kissing his
granddaughter not a 15 year old oh
that's better
oh that's way better
she was 19. oh he's kissing his ground
out on the lips that's totally fine
imagine having to type that like working
for the apes on the lips
do you think they believed that like
whoever wrote this do you think they
believed that when they were typing it
they were like oh no this is actually
this is totally different this is a bait
and switch yeah someone was like you
know you know the meme where it's if you
ever want to get the answer to a
question just post the wrong answer and
then someone
totally along the correct that's what it
is somebody was like i know that if i
share the image of biden kissing his
granddaughter the media will ignore it
so if i post the wrong thing that'll be
lovely
i just typed in biden smelling girl into
the search engine you should do the same
no no no
i actually will not be doing it
if you want to confirm what we're
talking about don't take my word for it
type biden smelling girl into the search
engine turn off the wi-fi if you're
doing that yeah i think he abused his
kid man well i think that's why hunter's
so messed up i did i just looked at the
math hunter was two when his when he was
in the car accident with his mom and
brother that died so
it's tough to say i mean
i don't know that would that would make
anyone i would imagine would be would
make sense i don't know
knowing that i'm not saying again
i know for a fact i'm just saying when i
look at someone like hunter biden who's
doing all these drugs who's really
messed up and sending his dad porn i'm
like ah sounds like his creepy dead who
sniffs children gropes them was probably
doing the same to his son i think they
both like porn and they both know they
both like porn it sounds to me like his
dad made it normal to share porn with
his son which is in itself disturbing
like when did that start i don't view
that as being i personally do not view
that as being normal i don't view that
as being wholesome in any way that's
disgusting
i don't know it does kind of seem like
one of those things where like when
you've when you've uh been a drug addict
for that long and especially if your
family doesn't discipline you when
you're younger and you don't find a way
to like get clean or get better and your
brain just gets more and more adult and
there's no repercussions for your
actions uh it's like escalating and
getting worse and getting worse and it's
just more noticeable to us because it's
such a prominent family
but i just don't know if uh i would
expect anything more if he didn't take
the i don't know if he's clean now if
he's doing better now but it's just not
something that i have a hard time
believing that he'd be able to get clean
without help and his dad's clearly not
helping him his family's too worried
about their public image that they're
having their uh
his messages and his laptop deleted and
uh you know kept out of the public
record they don't have time to worry
about how his actual health is
you know what though the biden family
they probably enjoy delicious meals of
crab from delaware excellent crabbing
country
so out in maryland we have excellent
crab cream of crab soup that's right
very wholesome for the family that
sounds delicious yeah it's really good
hungry thanks yeah i went to a
restaurant and they had uh lobster and
crab
really yeah it's very great is this
strange segway where are we yeah
what are we doing here nothing just
complete an entity
i was just imagining like you know we're
talking about hunter biden growing up
and i'm like they're in delaware or
whatever and i'm like they're probably
eating a lot of crab hey you know what's
in there go to the restaurants like
everything's scripted i think one thing
we didn't get to show is the the
pictures from that what was it the daily
mail article yeah i'm not showing those
no we can't show them but i mean if you
wonder if hunter's doing okay now look
at that article and look at those
pictures and that will answer the
question for you i don't know how old
the pictures are but he does not look
like he's doing good let's let's let's
uh so look joe biden's been miserable
let's talk about the story real quick we
got some timcast.com
kentucky democrat senate candidate wears
noose in new campaign ad criticizing
senator rand paul
in case you're wondering how democrats
are doing you need to look at this image
you know joe biden's doing miserably it
is they are they need a hail mary
desperate pass to try and pull this off
and so i we end up getting this ad where
an absolutely
desperate democrat candidate they know
they're losing now i don't know what's
going to happen for all we know
democrats end up winning sure fine
whatever the red wave is what's being
predicted because republicans are up in
the generic ballot
this guy
made a campaign ad with a noose around
his own neck huh and progressives were
calling it
bold
what courageous i'm like well that is
true
you got to have balls of steel to make a
campaign but when i saw this i was just
like it was kind of a moment of
realization for me
for the first it's the craziest
political ad i've ever i've seen in my
lifetime unless i'm forgetting something
which is possible there was another one
where they were like running people down
in maga trucks or something
that was also crazy but you know before
like growing up the campaign ads were
like my opponent wants to raise taxes
and he voted no on the safer schools act
now it's a guy he puts a noose around
his neck and he's like look what they've
done to me
wow like he put this noose around my
neck and said this is mega country
rand paul poured bleach on me outside of
subway that's right the media is like
rand what do you have to say for
yourself and he's like i didn't do it
and they're like he's lying he admits it
i i never did that like well that's what
you would say if you did it you did it i
do agree i've never seen an ad where
they make themselves the victim when
someone's running for office and it's
like look how badly i've been treated
vote for me that's also a very good
point that's such a bizarre strategy to
be like i
am a victim it's like
we were supposed to like leaders what is
this i got i do have to point out yes i
did not remember this one virginia ad
features minority kids chased by truck
with gillespie sticker and confederate
flag
yeah this is just the scare tactics
it's it's like they're writing fanfics
they aren't they are see but the
difference is this is a normal ad the
news
no yeah we'll play it
like what is this what is this white
dude the confederate flag doing they
made sure he turned his head slowly
though he's running down minority kids
what does it look like
but i don't think he actually does
anything to the kids he doesn't well
whoever whatever politician this was
probably intervened before he got a
chance to do so all right i bet he did i
actually know
i actually think this is a really good
commercial
run run run the truck is coming up girl
oh no
what's he gonna do what's it yeah like
what what is it what does the guy even
do oh no no not the gaston flag
ah
he's gonna run him over oh is this a
nightmare how did it become night so
fast
this is actually i think this is a good
commercial i know the psa is like maybe
stop fabricating fake hate crimes and
scaring the crap out of your children
exactly good idea these kids are having
nightmares because you scream in their
faces about things they don't got to be
worrying about for the most part the kim
klasik ads were really good that she had
those were good yeah that was a good
example of high production value uh but
focusing on whatever issues she wanted
to talk about in the community you know
walking the streets of baltimore i just
want to point out they took the tweet
they took that unbelievably banal
histrionic dramatic left-wing tweet that
we see every couple months and made a
commercial the my kids said to me i'm
scared because republican is going to do
x it's like your kid didn't say that
you're making this up what's wrong with
you they took they took that and they
made it a commercial do you remember the
the lincoln is it the lincoln project
project their commercial that they had
where it was like four more years and i
didn't know you could serve three terms
no it was uh it was um
it was donald trump in a pickup truck
chasing down abe lincoln probably yeah
jeez he hates america see but the thing
about these commercials is they're
i don't i don't want to give them any
sort of gravitas but at least they're
legit the thing with the noose is just a
publicity stunt yeah this guy's running
in kentucky against rand paul he knows
he's not going to win he's trying to get
twitter followers to parlay that into a
job at msnbc
that's his goal that's what a lot of it
always feels like to me is that they're
looking they know they're not going to
win especially in like specific
districts yeah he's trying to get
attention so that he can make his next
career move well he clearly literally
wants victim points by actually putting
a noose around his neck like i can't
think of a more direct parallel to being
like oh look at me i'm a victim give me
a job at msnbc
oh man we gotta wait we gotta watch let
me let me make sure good night america
america one of the funnier goodness
gracious
oh yeah blow this one up
don't let the bed bugs bite
look at that color scheme it's so dark
this is that meme where the kids like
mommy
donald trump is a fascist
it's like a red white like an american
flag blanket
[Music]
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
oh no he did not yes he did yes he did
the kid definitely did that no school
tomorrow
look at her face i thought you could
only be president
this is so cringe not anymore
hold on wait a minute she was
oh my gosh
what just one second all right just
besides everything that is obviously
wrong with this
if he was running for president after he
had already served two terms
why would the kid be confused about the
possibility of him winning
the idea that you can only have two
terms is not voter enforced it's not
like we let them run again and then the
american people don't know he had two
terms we're not voting but only after he
wins exactly oh no but it's literally
election night she says donald trump
might win and he goes wake me up when we
find out and then she wakes up and goes
but i thought you could only serve two
terms like why did you ask then why did
you ask
making me get up in the middle of the
night to tell you about something you
didn't even know about this uh son we've
been over this in some insane fascistic
way that the lincoln project dreamed up
he changed the law that's why he was
running again that's why there was the
election i gotta i gotta give a shout
out because this ad was actually like it
may as well have been a trump ad like an
ad for trump yeah dude and so yeah
like after all the trump supporters were
like yeah
like this is hilarious it's got more
play i think than anything it got more
so good remember the uh yeah whatever it
is remember the carpe dong meme
where it was like duh
2020 2024 2028 2032 and then it just
goes to infinity and they wrote articles
where they were like trump supporters
want trump to be president for life so
they're they're like they're like
trump would be president for more than
two terms you know who i love fdr best
president we ever had we need someone
like him
they worship the man he uh served four
terms as president by the way fdr before
the 22nd amendment was passed but he
died shortly into his face dudes served
so many terms they had to pass an
amendment they were like no
no more if you do so much of something
that someone has to pass a
constitutional amendment you are a
problem
they say that fdr was the most fascist
president he and woodrow wilson i don't
want to derail
no yeah that they were they're off they
were bad
two terms you think that's good
president should be able to serve
one term one six year term one six year
term yeah think about it i mean i'm not
entirely fully settled on this i just
think you know in terms of the president
having to run for re-election
when you get into the last two years of
their four-year term it turns into silly
season right and people start cutting
checks for
okay who do what vote do i need okay i
need minorities in wisconsin wisconsin
what do they need and then you federal
money goes to them like that like you
get rid of that with one six-year
presidential term now that that is
assuming that i believe the president
should have as much power as he does
which i do not or she does
uh so you know that's really insightful
it's very muddling to have a president
running for office and trying to be the
president yeah
well and i feel like i don't know that
doesn't seem crazy one six year term
like it seems like a yeah but
it's a good compromise for one four year
term is just not enough well one four
year term is yours you're
i don't know i can be swayed
yeah things happen fast now they happen
a lot faster than they used to
information travels a lot faster
well then they push stuff off to se like
they start pushing stuff off on their on
like what they plan to get done right so
they're like oh well we'll focus on that
for the second term so they start
pushing stuff on the agenda off until
term two you know under the context that
they're actually going to win so if you
give them one six year term that forces
them to do all that they want to work on
right then and then but then how do you
talk about like congress in the senate
like would that be along the same lines
as like uh
uh you know
don't keep in the weeds there
so this this this ad the good night
america thing was put up on october 22nd
2020. i just think it's funny that
they
they make this ad
and in 2019 we had the best numbers of
our lives in the in the economy
and so the worst thing they could think
of was that trump would just win again
because they had no real argument
against him
i i i honestly you'd ask people like
okay what don't you like about trump and
they'd be like he's a fascist or
whatever they wouldn't give you a real
reason
that's why that i think they made the
sad because they were like people don't
know why they hate trump they just want
him to go away and they don't want him
to go away because people are screaming
in their ears in the media
so they voted for a guy who tanked the
economy his son is driving gas prices
through the roof apparently is is
conversing on um the finer links to porn
with his child
just i mean the apple doesn't fall far
from the tree and so now here we are
the average person i mean man
spending like what you're gonna spend
like 70 to 100 bucks to fill up your gas
tank
but hey
three three terms of trump oh
that would have been the worst right
there was uh like literally the other
day i was scrolling instagram and i had
three stories in a row where it was like
friends posting their gas like filling
up their gas tank where it's like going
over 80 dollars and says thanks joe
biden and like all three of them were
like like one had like a sticker on it
one said thanks joe biden the other one
just was like a middle finger and it's
just all people focusing on the fact
that they can't afford to drive anymore
i swear i think it's the federal reserve
has been planning to crash this for a
while and they're blaming trump and
biden and they're making us blame trump
and biden and this has just been a
fascist move since they know it was
falling apart who's blaming trump
well some people some people they just
hate him and yeah but it's the these
guys are not the ones that caused this
this is like banking cartels let's talk
about i think the the uh the q and on
people who think he had a third term are
blaming him they're like why is he
letting this happen yeah that was that
was actually one of the things i will
give um
that was that guy's name jordan klepper
is that his name
he he's he talks to a q and guy and he's
like so you think trump is really the
president he's like yes he is he's like
why is he making gas prices so high and
the guy's like no that's joe biden he's
like but you said that trump was
president i'm like yeah okay those
people thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you